welcome to this last day failure your
favorite your best role-playing
annotation workshop hello and just
welcome to the final section of a
roleplay workshop for the NYC PI data I
just can't wait to see how we're
presenting so so who are we let's start
with some introductions I serve Lawrence
hey everyone Lawrence Warner Here I am
graduating a master's degree in Chicago
same program as Bhargav I'm heading back
to England I'm starting a company called
agile education where we're teaching
kids to learn to code today we're gonna
be treating teaching people who know how
to code to act like kids who everyone
like Lauren said I'm also at the
University of Chicago I'm a graduate
student I do mostly sociology and
anthropology stuff I saw a lot of NLP
stuff before we're gonna book on an Okie
as well this is what I normally do and
I'm happy to be the different parts of
the processes which you'll student out
mind if I don't know more about me or us
you can ask us my name is Agatha
I'm a software developer consultant at
ThoughtWorks for about a year a big part
of my work is running workshops and
transforming organizations transforming
how teams work and communicate my name
is Leah I used
I'm currently a data science team leader
trading desk but in previous life I was
a penalty engineer and like an
open-source maintainer so most of this
worship inspired by my consulting
practice in the positive and negative
way both what is this workshop about
this workshop is about the typical work
life cycle of an NLP project so you will
be experiencing how it is to be in a
engineer and annotator or a client who
has a problem that wants to be solved by
natural language processing and why is
this workshop great for you it might
happen that you are a highly experienced
an LP engineer who just recognized all
the struggles we're going to talk about
today there will be a few it might be
that you're a complete beginner you've
never experienced an LP project so it is
in either way this will be useful for
you
from one perspective you'll see the
perspective of the client
even the annotator and the flow of
information and communication between
them and you'll be able to explain the
complexities of your work to those
people so that you can in the future
communicate better if you haven't worked
on an LP it will also give you an
introduction to the project and to some
of the tools you might be using so what
we'll be doing today we have enough
about an hour and 20 minutes at this
point we'll be doing two exercises and
there'll be some discussion in the
middle so now I'd like you I'd like you
to team up I would like you to form
teams of three and each of you will be
joined by a game master
so go ahead please sit together move
around feel free to use the whole space
of the room so you might you might like
I think we should like maybe bring a
team over here at least to kind of have
a little space so make up why don't you
stay over that side do you guys want to
join her over there please thank you
let's use the whole space of the room
Deb you guys could go over to like this
side of the room you'll understand later
on what I'll banishing you to the corner
I'm gonna come hang out with you over
here
so do we have beans looks like we've got
exactly nine people I would like to
invite one of you to move for people
that's correct
that's good so we'll have one team of
foreign two teams of three that's
perfectly fine great and if you want to
communicate through the workshop when we
have any extra questions we have a slack
time you can have two right now and I'd
like you also to go to this website
through this workshop we'll be using our
laptops if you have your laptops with
you it's beneficial to go to this link
on your laptops yeah just type it just
open up your browser either on desktop
or mobile and type in NLRB tech and you
will see what you need to do so once
you've opened up the web page
you should see a link for our current
workshop here and for participants to
click on the blue button to open up the
slides
everyone have everyone reached their
website and their dislikes but before
before you join the team maybe you can
explain the slides okay listen up
everyone
does everyone does all the participants
in the room have their slides open you
should be on this slide up here right
now if anyone's not on the game dynamics
slide please raise your hand
great so the game dynamic it's a game
we're gonna have some fun you each have
assigned to you a game master that group
has left this group actually has two
game masters by the looks of it
Bhargav and mega and I will be your game
master we know what's gonna happen but
you shouldn't really need to call on us
a huge amount because I argit's over
here the master of the game masters so
to speak has designed some rather
exquisite slides for you all on these
slides you will see they essentially
guide you through a narrative of the
gameplay and there's two main ways that
you go forward through the game firstly
there may be times when there's timers
for a specific action that will last a
certain length of time and here you'll
see a hyperlink which will open up a
timer which automatically starts so I'd
encourage you all to turn the sound on
your laptop's on and otherwise you
should be instructed on when to proceed
through the slides
and if it says this then don't click Add
please right so now is the time when we
will decide which roles we're going to
be playing in our first playthrough of
the game so it is now time to click to
click ahead and choose the role that you
will be playing so do we have a good way
of okay so clockwise from the game
master are we ready
first person please raise your hand if
you are the client please raise your
hand and click on the hyperlink client
next person round you are our
technological wizard you are NLP
engineer please click on the NLP
engineer button and finally I am sorry
to say that you will be our annotator
this means that you will be doing
something for free that you usually get
paid next to nothing to do as everyone
clicked through onto their role slides
right guys so now we are about to enter
our first game and please look at your
slides and do as instructed and call
upon your game master if you have any
questions whatsoever we will next come
together as a room in around 20 minutes
[Music]
I'm getting in such a clown line without
being that Christian so this is 3 X 5
bonus just might either come in first
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we actually we actually there's nobody
in that
[Music]
okay what are you
basically let's just have a look I just
is it the other bottlers yes is this
intelligence or artificial plug is in
each hurry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
great everyone I think everyone has the
chance to finish the exercise and
discuss how it felt for everyone in the
team so now we're going to move on to
discussion so maybe if you if you sorry
slight whole discussion us as a larger
group if there is anything that you feel
like that you'd like to come together
I got a mic here I can bring around as
well I can talk I'll bring the mic
rounds different groups most are over
here with my boy dark if there is
something discussed in your group do you
think is valuable for everyone to know
please do share yeah so sometimes what
happens in Cincy is a buzzword nowadays
like management who doesn't know
anything about AI they'd somehow they
ask the question to that team that okay
should we use AI and sometimes people
out of either fear or because they want
to get promoted they will somehow try to
fit a I but there are many problems
which can be solved without using AI by
simplest simple heuristics
so that's something that we need to keep
in mind that use AI whenever it's really
beneficial
[Music]
and now I'm gonna head over to bargains
group does anyone have anything here
that they want to share out Mauricio
about like your industry maybe you want
to talk with a mysterion and how they
decline actually has to get involved
because of the very technical nature of
the things well it's up to you if you
wanted if you want something to share
please go ahead yeah you should also
leave yeah I so I was the annotator in
our group and it was as I was saying at
these guys it was a good exercise in
just like highlighting the like sheer
brutality of just like what that kind of
work involves and how like this
particular kind of annotation was
particularly trying because there is as
I told them like there's no way to do it
on autopilot
you're not like looking for something in
a row making something out of it and
then just filling in that cell you have
to navigate through different parts the
internet I've actually curious to see
what other people try it for the
employee count or like thank you IG for
sharing that I think that's a really
common experience for folks who do the
annotation and find out quite how
infuriating a task it is anyone in this
group wanna share I think in response to
Andrew otherwise not too much more based
on what everyone said but I for a number
of employees I'd like to do a marketing
pitch for glassdoor.com that had the
number of employees for all of the
larger bakeries so he's told that fall
tillage bakeries and done two small ones
I just lied and scented with one 215
decline
okay can I just request the geography
removes that section from the videos and
future editions of the watch don't get
the full learning experience and the
frustration and we have another person
who wants to share sure so one of the
things that I was talking about being
really frustrating was that as an
annotator I wasn't able to convenient to
communicate directly with the client
which I found incredibly frustrating
because I couldn't get you know
specifics about what the client was
actually looking for so then we weren't
necessarily sure what specifics were
needed and of course because everything
was time bound you know you just had to
dive into the work without asking very
many questions when I tonight I would
like I also have two client like why
they're using this data and I said was
proprietary which in my mind with
corporate synergy buzzword for they
actually I don't know what they were
gonna do with that
I didn't formally say that and they will
be the case now how about target say do
we have any more time for group
discussion or do we want to go to the
structured right so I'll first like kind
of question for discussion like I'll
bring the mic over to anyone who wants
to share thoughts on this just put your
hand up to like annotators there's three
of you like who do you guys think should
do the annotation so like do you think
it was the right choice that you alone
were tasked with doing the annotation
okay so over here we had we had like
some more collaboration going on do you
think that was a better experience cool
so more people the better would you guys
agree over here yeah okay cool I think
that's like if you look at just one
website you would build is done a broker
please no announcer here so yeah like
really everyone involved in the project
should have some hands-on experience
with the data even in its messiest form
right now to my three clients my
business owners what do you think
then I'll pH engineer should have done
when you ask them to do the impossible
anyone came to just be honest if you're
not able to do something just say that
you can't or if you need like if you
can't meet the time expectations you
know be upfront
don't don't drag people like along you
know like that's all any any any
agreements or disagreements with that
agreements over otherwise he'll be lost
like where the project at which point it
is we come back from that so we heard
over in the other side of the room the
thought like hey like you got to get it
done like everyone like like that
teaching Python are these boot camps now
I can hire like a hundred other people
if you can't get it done I'm gonna hire
someone who can like what do you think
an engineer should say under that
environment
exactly it's a really hard question
basically under capitalism under
capitalism it's really really hard not
to lie at some point so props to you for
staying honest folks who do actually
what would be even easier if instead of
getting that information from another
engineer you would have yourself as a
client look at the data and seen it for
yourself or do it as a group so I was
lien for saying if you the most
successful startups have everyone in the
process involved in annotation and now
finally for the three NLP engineers like
do you have any thoughts on a better
strategy for solving this problem if
like say you know in the next half an
hour we were going to you know try to
solve the same problem again well
probably we will hire this guy so
broadly speaking we might say like there
might be some better tools that we might
be able to use and actually we're
actually going to introduce you to one
really useful annotation tool and and
we've already talked about better
approaches including more collaboration
amongst all three people in the project
so yeah with that in mind
okay so yeah we heard some good
suggestions and in part two we can put
them into practice so let me just don't
summarize the suggestions a bit more
let's go so we learn from annotators
that the client and then at least I
would be engineer but the client is even
better should be involved negotiate
scope should be involved annotation if
client has seen at least one website
they would know that number from place
is not there so that would be very easy
to have this scoping negotiation of them
if they actually familiar with the data
its point one and secondly as we heard
very well from there it's the engineers
responsibility to not waste clients time
it just creates analytic expectations if
you spend she weighs six months of my
time and like okay you pay you the day
rate but this is zero at the end of it
it's really bad for me I would rather
you told me like you know we're gonna
deliver ten percent in two months rather
than just get zero of the six months
that's a responsibility after engineer
and in NLP the main part of an LP in
industry is actually not about learning
knowing some deep learning algorithms or
like tuning your deep learning networks
it's more about splitting the problem
the business problem that comes to you
into well-known NLP chunks and they're
well to you well-known NLP chunks here
it's like you know ten conferences a
year on text categorization if you have
a text how to categorize if it's a
bakery or a bagel shop or daily that's
just one problem
and you can have have like one separate
invoice for that one separate stream for
that just for categorizing things and
the second thing that happen here is
called information extraction is that we
have a page and you just need to find
the address just extracting one
particular piece of information from the
page so I would actually make it as two
different projects and sale it like okay
let's do one of them this monofin
another one next month or you could hire
two different teams to do two different
projects that's like that's a really
good skill to use that's about scoping
let's talk more about tools so the tool
used here is Google sheets you know it's
a well-known and ope tool you know
it's free everybody's using it it's like
it's like it's one of the source of
frustration here is definitely Google
sheets there's a much better tool that
we're gonna use in part two
it's called prodigy it's one of the
annotation user interfaces out there
there are links to it in the end
there's some proprietary some open
source versions out there so this is
what the UI looks like and first you
look it is like what am I looking at you
know it doesn't make any sense
doesn't look like a website at all so
this is a small snippet of text you only
looking at one small snippet at a time
you're not looking at the whole website
and we came from midfield and by NYC
comm website the URL is in the bottom
right if you click on it you can see
their full website if you want and we
don't show you the whole website because
we want you to focus and not miss
anything you just see like one little
bit of the time you can read it all and
easily mechanically do it like somebody
mentions can you do this mechanically
and it was really hard this is actually
much more mechanical than that
and you see this and you highlight three
things if there's a name of the business
owner you highlight it and it is
highlighted here in yellow you see that
has a chef Olivia the son it is
highlighted here in yellow and that's
the job of annotators to highlight
things here and once the highlighted it
he click green and it saves an
annotation database this thing you will
play with it in a second part and you
can you be able to test more more
questions about it later cool so this
yellow thing yep I can change
Hey so this yellow thing this is a date
annotator has to fill out themselves
and there is a way that we can give them
suggestions so they don't have to do it
from scratch we can just already prepare
something which looks kind of like an
owner looks kind of like an address kind
of like a business name and they just
have to say yes or no correct it
slightly it's much easier than just
starting from scratch and yeah I can use
the best III in the world in the cold
area X that's my favorite il girl you
know it's not natural intelligence
artificial intelligence and if there's
any time there five digits in a row
that's a postcode and it's very easy for
me to do and actually for a client it
may be even all they want to know
because they can figure out if it's a
risky neighborhood where businesses go
bankrupt or maybe it's a safe
neighborhood or businesses don't go
bankrupt Bosco is actually very useful
it's very easy for me to find just and I
just need to write one line of JSON and
prodigy finds me all the five digits you
know strings out there it might not all
be post codes I still have to filter
them by hand but at least like it's a
good candidate right do you agree okay
cool
what about business owner and business
name and here I can also use a pre
trained model there are ready-made
models called named entity recognition
models the recognized organization names
and organize people names it's not like
based on a list of organizations it
actually just looks at the structure for
sentence where it appears what are the
words around it and it just like
something it looks likely like a name of
a business and I can use that for this
thing I also added geographical names as
a name of a business because like
Liberty bagels Midtown Midtown is name
of geography but it's actually name of a
business as well so I put it all
together it's like I suggest many more
things which actually true but I would
rather not lose anything you know and
this this day just want to generate a
lot of suggestions good candidates and I
just added this free lines into prodigy
config you know label business name
anything which is at entity type org a
label business name anything which
entity type geopolitical entity like a
country or city and business owner just
any kind of person not every person
listed on the webpage will be a business
owner
but I will start with owner and I'll
find you in this model later if I want
to start from scratch you'll have to
teach the model 100,000 examples of
people's names and that's really hard I
already start with something like a nice
people and just fine-tune it a bit you
know to give me who is the owner on on
that page and that's what a clever way
to do a new peak quickly you just start
with something which is free and already
pre trained and just tuned a little bit
it for your business problem so they're
gonna use the suggestions in the second
part cool
so to summarize we learned that 3x is
the best III if regular solves the
problem please use it you know like I
talked by this big deep learning
researcher and how he's saying how
really wants to work on reg X's because
like that's what actually powers the
industry secondly if you can find a pre
trained model which is really close to a
business problem like if you want to
find people who are like commit crimes
start with model that just finds people
and then tune it to find if it's
connected to criminals and thirdly just
use annotation UI it's much more fun
than Google Spreadsheets you will show
you the party let's move on to party
so now we're gonna change the rules so
person who was the client becomes the
annotator the person who was the NLP
engineer becomes the client and an
annotator becomes an LP engineer that's
how we can do it now so let's open your
slides again and you'll go back to your
game masters
the same story like 20 Moreland
we're supposed to talk to you which are
original for feedback you can come up
with a better one
I still I mean
[Music]
I'm one of you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you could just like ended my liner
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how what if it's actually
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
we need to wrap up I said actually so
we're gonna spend on the annotation
maybe this part of the
okay guys I know you're having a lot of
fun with prodigy and I hope it's
something you will want to get together
to do your own time but now we want to
thank you for joining us and look
towards wrapping up the session so we're
not gonna spend as much time recapping
the second playthrough we hope you'll
agree that it was a much better approach
in many ways including the full
following specific ways number one the
client got stuck in which is great
because they meant they weren't just
bullshitting
number two and they and they you know
and they provided really good manpower
is that was really good number two we
had communication across the whole team
that's awesome
number three we weren't like start going
down this annoying rabbit hole around
number of employees which was never
gonna go anywhere
don't mention class Thor and number four
we used you know we leverage awesome
tools which made our work genuinely more
efficient so I hope that like second
playthrough is what all of your future
LP projects look like and more broadly
all of your tech consulting looks like
and you know if you do want to continue
putting these what you've learned into
practice those annotation tools you can
you know always come back to the slides
you know bookmark these slides and you
know here we go like we got prodigy
there and prodigy you know they are
trying to make some money so there's a
free open-source version called picanha
and then like if you you know you do
want to you know use NLP models and you
don't want have to train on yourself
there's this awesome
open-source project called Spacey and
again the folks behind prodigy have made
a nice UI around Spacey which they could
display see but also we want to give a
shout out for an ogee NLP package in
Python called Jensen which a
collaborators Lev and Bhargav of heavily
contributed to and finally you know if
spacey in this space in general is
interesting there is an awesome free
online course which we're linking to and
then finally if you enjoyed your time
today and more generally feel that it's
a really worthwhile endeavor for both
for anyone involved in in technology
projects to think and work through what
it might look like to better communicate
amongst each other and in particular how
we can bridge the gap the communication
gap between technologists and laypeople
like we would love if you want to tell
your people about NL RP so that's the
website to pass on so yeah just a wrap
from all of us for we want to say thank
you all for like coming on the like the
final session of the final day of Pi
data New York 2019 and from laughs I
gotta myself and Bhargav we hope you
enjoyed our Python workshop for humans
thank you very much
[Applause]